here's what would happen if you fell  into a black hole  as you started being pulled toward a  black hole you'd be moving faster and  faster  accelerated by the force of gravity if  you were being pulled toward  a stellar black hole you'd be completely  torn apart so  make sure you choose a supermassive  black hole then  your body would remain unharmed as you  cross the event horizon  at the center of the black hole there's  a gravitational singularity  that's where density becomes infinite  you would be squashed into that center  and become  one with the black hole when the black  hole  eventually died it would spew out all  the particles  it had absorbed including your body  unfortunately it would be impossible to  tell which of those particles  were once you so would you dare explore  this possibility  i know i wouldn't because